there was four packer offensive linemen
here because
they were in pitch perfect two
right pitch perfect two
and they were all here and they showed
off their singing voices with clay
matthews
in that one but last night this man was
front and center his
his beard chugging ability appears
second to none and uh and it went viral
he is none other than david bach tiara
here on the richardson show from the
green bay packers how are you david
i'm good how you doing i'm doing fine um
is is
is this this is with all due respect
because you're an all-pro player
you know a pro bowl guy as well is this
the the best
uh skill that you have david his shotgun
and beers
that we saw last night um
i maybe i mean i i hadn't tapped into
that
no 12 is getting a little bit of heat he
just he just couldn't finish david there
was just no
there was no burst you know what i mean
there was no burst lack of burst
yeah i mean um i'm not gonna speak on
his behalf
but uh i will say that uh at least on my
end
they were smooth they were cold and they
did taste well for
the amount of time that i was able to
taste them i told you brock when he was
going to protect aaron rodgers coming on
this show that's your default right
david
you will protect aaron rodgers every
single day every single situation
that you could possibly be in in that
position correct david
i mean it's my job it's kind of uh
becoming second nature at this point so
i i mean that's my guy that's my
quarterback that's my guy
i mean i'll be on his beer chugging team
i'll help him out
yeah so uh because to me i just said in
the previous segment david bakhtiari
here in the ritual that to me
uh again i'm not a beard chugger uh by
trade
like if if pressed i would do uh and i
think i could accomplish
but normally i'm a wine guy
uh uh aaron looked to me like he
normally sips
when he has some sort of alcoholic
beverage as you said
scotch guy right yeah i mean i
i mean the guy drinks scotch like a fish
drinks water
so i mean i've seen it like when we're
at the kentucky derby i saw
i mean the guy can definitely enjoy that
now beer i mean i think
i think that's more of a lineman thing i
guess yeah and again
that that takes back to uh my college
i don't know where it's still i mean i
guess it's still sharpened
that uh that talent of mine but it had
been a while since i
had enjoyed beer like that now did
yelich know that he was getting involved
in this too
or that was just a total audible as well
david
that was 100 notable that was we'll have
a beer
right in front of you and get that
camera on you for the next tv timeout
okay
and he said all right let's do it about
five minutes later he's standing up
like gladiator and joined the fans then
down to the beer and i couldn't have
been prouder
two mvps are chugging the same night i
mean that's an accomplishment
of itself david that is an
accomplishment no one can ever take that
away from you
nobody can ever take that away from you
no matter how hard they try
now yelich did see again uh uh i'm
i'm an observer that's what i do for a
living did see there was a little
spillage though that he did
there was a little struggle towards him
but he did finish he did finish last
night right
true exactly what you don't want to
happen when it comes to chelsea beer i
know plus two everybody
expects an athlete to be able to do it
david you know what i'm saying everybody
it's certainly in wisconsin
everyone expects that i think the theme
for this week as many are called but if
you were chosen
[Laughter]
now okay let's cut to monday let's let's
let's assume the deer is in fact
fearsome
in game six and we're back in phi serve
being over served on monday
do you give aaron rodgers any tips
on how to finish this time because we
can't have it a second time we this this
can't happen again i think we can
potentially all agree
on that slippery slope david what what
what do you say to that
in terms of giving tips to 12 should
this
happen again i think you either redeem
yourself which i know the competitor in
him would
do or go with what go with what works
for you
grab that scotch and i mean i don't
think anyone would think anything less
of a man who
slams his scotch in front of the fans
before game seven
when they're back at home but if it is a
beer i mean you gotta stand up that's
number one right
i mean it's you gotta stand up you gotta
use gravity
gravity is your friend you got to stand
up you got to hold from the top too
right i mean the
angle of the beard plays a big factor
when chugging the less angle and slope
that you have for the beer to flow
you know the slower it's going to be the
more your throat's going to want to
try and over compensate and swallow and
i think you know
you're going to be caught behind the
eight ball and kind of having that
freakout moment mm-hmm
that's a great attack you have to attack
it yeah i see you your your style
is to hold from the top i mean aaron as
you know was like holding from the
bottom he
he kind of palmed it you you're you're
going from top down
and just tilting and going you're
opening up and just
swallowing that's what i see yeah
uh again this is all from the college
days
back didn't practice this is just kind
of by nature
i'm going to default mode now when you
uh
went to david bochter a few more minutes
left here with the
the packers offensive lineman when you
went to the derby with uh with aaron did
you guys have maximum security did
anybody bet on country house
what was that situation did anybody cash
the ticket
that day um you know this was
the most i've won now i think this is my
third kentucky derby this is the most
i've won so i only lost a little bit
this trip um no no one hit big
i know last year jimmy graham came up i
think it was about almost 15 grand
he he had a good number but this year
there was no big winners
well we're showing a shot of you guys
the posse if you will and david i say
this with the only ultimate respect
that maroon um that maroon suit that
you're wearing
it looks like a very dumb and dumber
type shirt
and outfit is that what you were going
for without the top hat
obviously um i
wasn't you know i was
i was trying to be stylish but i think
being a very big man
trying to fit into a little suit fat guy
in a little suit
it's almost tougher to look stylish and
go with the exotic colors but you know
what
when it's derby weekend i try to pull it
all off and if
it ends up being the dumb and dumber
look i'll take it i have the little
horses on my shirt i had a lot of fun
with it it was
a suit by alba they're great and uh
it fit perfectly because i did i can't
see the design
on the photograph it looks like that
ruffled sort of shirt
so it's it's just a flat shirt but it's
horses with a regular white collar
that's what you got working right there
okay exactly and my bad then my bad now
do you know
again not to make this like an ank the
end of anchorman here
but you know brady is going to be
rolling in with his guy and his posse
and you know you've got your own 12 here
rolling in is there some sort of
competition
about dress about anything
showing up at the derby with aaron
rodgers knowing brady's bringing his
posse as well
david no no it's it's it's all fun um
okay
we end up getting about four tables next
to each other and it's just a riot
you know we're mixing imagine we're you
know sharing drinks we're talking about
who's betting on who everyone's rushing
over to place their best
i mean it's a really big party i gotta
say brady's group
they they they come and they're very
loud
speaker that they they let everyone know
they're there and that's awesome they
bring so much energy into that
environment it's fantastic so you're
mingling you're the brady and aaron
rodgers groups are mixing
at the at the derby oh yeah oh fantastic
i didn't know that you guys were all
hanging out like that that's that's very
united nations that's
like bringing together as one david i am
i'm
very pleased to hear that piece of
information all right well
um do i say congratulations
based on the evening from last night
um no not yet okay when we go back for
game seven
and when i when i do the beers the right
way and how many more
how how many i need to do to get it done
to have them win
that's when we'll get a congratulations
okay so
it's got to be four right i mean
you you got to have it ready at your
feet i guess
yeah i mean i'll be honest it's pretty
funny i literally got
handed beers on a silver platter last
night when i showed up
there's a presentation of beers on the
silver platter with cups
they're like here is your your weapons
um
do as you will as like an assassin like
rolling out like looking at all these
utensils i'm like okay
here we go i got i gotta press i gotta
get ready gotta get the foam down
make it nice and easy to make sure
they're in the cups it's always easier
inside the cup
and i was gonna have at it so i guess
yeah
if it needs to be four okay i'll do four
if you need to be five i'll do five as
many
until the packers tell me no more
because now it's uncomfortable for us
and we need you to stop
i get i think that's what i'll pull back
i love it and you send one over to drake
too wherever the hell he is and see what
he can do with that
david oh yeah i'd love to see that you
know what i mean
i think that would be great oh yeah well
david i appreciate you calling in it's
been too long
hopefully this will just be a regular
thing with uh having you on the show
just chatting
i really appreciate it absolutely that
was fun i appreciate it
you got it that was a lot of fun that
was a lot of fun not just last night but
uh today too thanks for the call bud
of course you got that's david bachtier
packers offensive lineman the john wick
of beer slugger for more of the rich
eisen show
tune to audience channel 239 on directv
for free on br live or download the rich
eisenshow app